und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend whatever it takes egal was es
kostet
seit ein ezb präsident draghi aus
italien mit diesem motto scheinbar die
letzte große finanzkrise erschlug
grassiert in krisenlagen weltweit eine
fast kultische verehrung gewaltiger
geldbeträge heute in brüssel für die
heilung der pandemie folgen in der
europäischen union hat die eu kommission
unter ursula von der leyen die
unfassbare summe von 750.000 millionen
euro aufgerufen
das war's dann aber auch schon mit
monströsen zahlen ab sofort geht es um
ganz kleine im europa der 27 nationen
braucht es 27 zustimmung bevor irgendein
teil des von der leyen plans was werden
kann
das ist noch nicht ausgemacht stefan
leifert berichtet die frau die auftritte
kontrolliert wie keine zweite lässt
heute wenig zweifel dass dies die
wichtigste die wichtigste rede ihrer
amtszeit werden soll
mit pathos und historie wird ursula von
der leyen für einen plan der europa neu
erfinden soll
diese baut in dieser krise geht es um
uns alle und sie übersteigt jeden
einzelnen von uns dies ist europas
moment moment die korona
krisenbewältigung als projektierer
generation kleiner geht es heute nicht
die kommissionspräsidentin wirbt für nie
dagewesenes hoch umstrittenes gemeinsame
schulden aller eu-länder diejenigen
denjenigen die heute die mutige
investitionen scheuen
denen sage ich lasst uns morgen die
kosten des nichthandelns in dieser krise
viel viel teurer zu stehen kommen hier
geht es darum gemeinsam grundlagen für
unsere zukunft zu legen
die eu kommission würde für den
wiederaufbau plan am kapitalmarkt 750
milliarden euro aufnehmen 500 milliarden
gibt sie davon als zuschüsse weiter 250
als kredite profitieren sollen vor allem
die am schwersten betroffenen
krisenländer italien bekäme 103 und
70 milliarden spanien 140 auf
deutschland würden 29 entfallen die
schulden sollen über 30 jahre
zurückgezahlt werden
das ist so sage ich das ganz deutlich
komplett irre der für diesen irrsinn von
den bürgern der union zu entrichtende
preis wird gigantisch sein sie werden
mit dem geld nicht ihrem sondern dem der
steuerzahler nur so um sich als gäbe es
kein morgen aus spanien und italien
kommt beifall das signal aus brüssel sei
richtig sagt italiens premier konnte
opposition gegen milliarden ohne
rückzahlung hingegen aus wien und den
haag und heftiger wir haben zusammen mit
dänemark österreich und schweden einen
anderen ausgangspunkt vorgeschlagen wie
wir uns den wiederaufbau von vorstellen
nämlich in der kombination mit einem
modernen haushalt und notwendigen
reformen in ländern die nun auf hilfe
angewiesen sind damit sie sich beim
nächsten mal selbst helfen können woche
wird der woche die jetzt aufgebaut und
uns ist wichtig natürlich dass hier über
das verhältnis zuschüsse und kredite
verhandelt wird noch einmal es gibt
jetzt erstmals einen entwurf am tisch
und das ist der startpunkt für die
verhandlungen mit ihrem plan geht die
eu-kommission noch über den merkel makro
plan hinaus der sa 500 milliarden euro
vor
das prinzip aber ist ähnlich dass das
jetzt noch schwierige verhandlungen
werden ist klar die werden aus den
nächsten eu hat nicht abgeschlossen
werden
das ziel muss es sein dass wir im herbst
genügend zeit finden für die nationalen
parlamente und für das europäische
parlament die dinge zu beraten so dass
sie alle zum 11 12 01 21 dann in kraft
treten können
noch nie ging es um solch gigantische
summen von der mutter aller schlachten
sprechen sie schon in brüssel
nach schneller einigung klingt das
wahrlich nicht der deutsche manfred
weber chef der konservativen fraktion im
europa parlament hätte
eu-kommissionspräsident werden können
hätten nicht mag und merkel in letzter
minute die deutsche ursula von der leyen
aus dem hut gezogen
herr weber guten abend hätten sie heute
die gleiche rede gehalten
ursula von der leyen das gleiche
gefordert guten abend der kleber und ja
ich hätte das gleiche gefordert
weil dieser kontinent wir europäer uns
in der größten wirtschaftskrise seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg befinden und jetzt
geht es einfach um die frage starten wir
gemeinsam durch oder werden wir
gemeinsam zu den verlierern und auch die
deutsche volkswirtschaft kann nur durch
starten wenn der binnenmarkt
funktioniert in europa insgesamt
wirtschaftlich wieder auf die füße kommt
deswegen müssen wir jetzt investieren
jetzt schmeißen sie für diesen neustart
aber eiserne prinzipien europas über
bord zum beispiel das prinzip so lange
es keine einheitliche wirtschafts und
finanzpolitik gibt ist jedes land für
seine geldausgaben selber zuständig
trägt selber das risiko darf aber auch
selber entscheiden das wird nun mit 500
milliarden euro
aufgeweicht zunächst die vorschläge die
heute vorgelegt worden sind bedingt
bewegen sich im rahmen der verträge der
rechtsgrundlage der europäischen union
das ist fundamental wichtig und das wird
auch respektiert und dann muss man
dazusagen länder wie italien und spanien
sie können nichts für corona sie können
nichts dafür dass sie die ersten waren
die betroffenen sind auf der betroffen
waren auf diesem kontinent
das war vor zehn jahren bei der euro
krise noch was anderes das damals
wirklich das argument gezählt hat wer
seine hausaufgaben nicht macht kann auch
nicht auf solidarität bauen bei corona
ist das was anderes wir sitzen im
gemeinsamen boot und wenn ich das noch
sagen dafür die psychologische wirkungen
in unseren nachbarländern muss man auch
sehen dass wir bereits vor zehn jahren
schon einmal eine verlorene generation
hatten wo junge menschen perspektivlos
oft besser ausgebildete menschen
perspektivlos waren und ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass wir europäer uns
eine zweite verlorene generation leisten
ich wiederhole wir sitzen in einem boot
wir wollen durchstarten und entscheidend
ist dass die gelder die wir jetzt
einnehmen für zukunfts interessen
verwandt werden und nicht verfrühstückt
werden nun gibt es ja vier länder deren
zustimmung sie brauchen werden die
sogenannten sparsamen 4
die niederlande schweden dänemark und
für uns am nächsten liegende österreich
die bisher gesagt haben wir machen nicht
mit wenn 500 milliarden euro quasi als
geschenke oder hilfszahlungen
einbahnstraße gegeben werden mit uns
gibt's nur kredite wie wollen sie die
entweder kaufen oder überzeugen
es ist eine lebendige diskussion die
jetzt läuft und ich habe sowohl beim bei
den vier angesprochenen staaten als auch
beim rest der europäischen union heute
zunächst immer den satz gehört
solidarität ist notwendig europa muss
jetzt zusammenstehen das sagt sebastian
kurz gesagt man könnte sagen viele
auf diesem kontinent und das ist doch
eine gute startvoraussetzungen über die
details werden wir jetzt gingen
natürlich wird man den den vorschlag von
heute als grundlage nehmen und wir
werden jetzt darüber bringen wie wir das
ganz konkret machen
ich glaube wenn wir dem die vier staaten
die anforderungen uns genau anschauen
dann ist ein zentraler punkt wichtig
denn heute die kommission aufgenommen
hat nämlich die gelder werden gebunden
an reformauflagen italien spanien andere
werden sich verändern müssen sie müssen
selbst auf die füße kommen sie bekommen
unterstützung aber wie sind die
solidarität ist ich kann meine nachbarn
nur dann um unterstützung bitten
wenn ich selbst meine hausaufgaben
machen und dieses kriterium der
sparsamen 4
das wird eingehalten und umgesetzt auch
von kommissionsvorschlag und das ist
auch richtig
die archive von zeitungen und von prüf
anstalten und von fernsehsendern sind
voll mit beiträgen über verschleuderte
oder sinnlos eingesetzte manchmal
gesetzwidrig eingesetzte europa
milliarden wie wollen sie bei diesem
riesenpaket dass jetzt plötzlich vom
himmel fällt dafür sorgen dass so etwas
nicht mehr passiert das europäische
parlament der gesetzgeber in europa wird
jetzt bei den vergabekriterien klare
vorgaben machen für was das geld
verwendet werden darf zunächst natürlich
die korona direkten folgen abzufedern
aber dann muss in die zukunft investiert
werden
und dann haben wir eine
haushaltskontrolle in europa die sich
dem annimmt wir werden alles tun müssen
damit wir dafür sorgen dass die gelder
ordentlich dort ankommen wo sie
hinsollen und dafür ist auch notwendig
dass wir über einen rechtsstaats
mechanismus reden
unabhängige journalisten sind dabei
wichtig unabhängige gerichte sind
wichtig in den staaten und für mich ist
auch klar geld da kann nur der bekommen
der genau diese prinzipien von
europäischen rechtsstaat auch
respektiert und in seinem land umsetzen
und wann wird das alles die kuh
sozusagen vom eis sein in dieser sache
ja es wäre wichtig dass es schnell geht
sieht weil wir brauchen jetzt ein signal
an die bürger vor allem auch an die
wirtschaft wir halten zusammen wir
glauben an uns wir investieren in die
zukunft
wir lassen uns von china jetzt nicht
wirtschaftlich den rang ablaufen wir
europäer können mithalten
das ist die botschaft die wir brauchen
und deswegen hoffe ich dass der juni rat
bereits große fortschritte bringt besten
wäre es wenn wir uns nochmal
handlungsfähig werden wären damit
spätestens nächstes jahr zu beginn des
nächsten jahres der haushalt offiziell
starten kann
danke für das gespräch und einen schönen
namen
ich bedanke mich und damit zu deutscher
innenpolitik die kanzlerin traf sich
heute virtuell mit den kollegen
regierungschefs der ostdeutschen länder
das ist ein gespanntes verhältnis
speziell bei corona das virus macht ja
keine unterschiede wirkt aber
verschieden in ost und west die
wirtschaftsstruktur ost ist anders als
im westen
es gibt da weniger tief verwurzelte
großkonzerne eigentlich gar keine
die industrie ist eher mittelständisch
hat wenig reserven ist anfälliger für
krisen umgekehrt aber sind sie im osten
weniger betroffen von corona viel
weniger infizierte dünner besiedelt
keine tradition von karneval und keine
ski trips in die alpen sozusagen als
allgemeingut das sind jetzt in der phase
der lockerung interessen ost natürlich
anders als interessen des andreas weise
chef unseres studios sachsen anhalt
erklärt es gibt schon gründe dafür dass
einige der lockersten lockerungs ideen
gerade von osten kommen nicole und
jacqueline sprung in einer ihrer 18
filialen in burg bei magdeburg die
familiengeführte becker und konditorei
kette leidet 30 prozent weniger umsatz
jeden tag auch wenn wieder kunden kommen
das sind bei weitem nicht mehr so viele
wie früher
und nicht nur das steckt heftig ins
kontor
uns fehlt natürlich dass im haus
geschäft die leute können wir uns nicht
mehr feiern
sie können sich nicht mehr treffen so
könnte ich mir vor ort sachen verzehren
wir haben kitas beliefert wir haben
hotels beliefert auch das wird uns und
das hat uns ganz schön hart getroffen
ihr problem sie haben mehr als 50
mitarbeiter sind so zu groß für
soforthilfen und kredite eine halbe
million euro investierten sie letztes
jahr neue öfen jetzt war wieder ein
kredit nötig das budget nun schwer
belastet kein einzelfall für die
handwerkskammer magdeburg ihre forderung
direkte finanzhilfen auch für betriebe
mit mehr als 50 mitarbeitern gerade hier
in relativ kleinteilig strukturierten
gegenden wie in sachsen anhalt wo der
mittelstand getragene wirtschaft säule
ist brauchen wir dieses zuschussprogramm
weil viele haben schon einen
kapitaldienst zu leisten sie haben
investiert die können keine weiteren
kredite aufnehmen das würde ihr rating
erheblich verschlechtern und die kann
schlicht und einfach mit den jetzt
geringeren umsätzen den kapitaldienst
auch nicht erfüllen nicht nur in sachsen
anhalt im ganzen osten haben viele
unternehmen ein gemeinsames problem die
finanzdecke ist oft zu dünn
vor dem virus glänzte die ostdeutsche
wirtschaft mit guten wachstumsraten nun
droht vielen firmen der freie fall
das war heute auch thema bei der video
konferenz der kanzlerin mit den
ostdeutschen ministerpräsidenten schon
deutlich formuliert worden von dem
ministerpräsidenten dass wir dort auch
durch gezielte förderung im rahmen der
soforthilfen der konjunkturpaket auch
unterstützung der bundesregierung
erwarten damit wir eben mit diesen
positiven entwicklungen der letzten
jahre weiter arbeiten können und weiter
vielen menschen auch eine gute
perspektive und zukunft bieten können
doch die ost länder haben auch niedrige
corona fallzahlen wie zum beispiel
sachsen anhalt wirtschaftsminister
willingmann fordert deshalb schon seit
april mehr lockerungen will die
besonders betroffenen wirtschaftszweige
wie gastronomie und hotels deutlich mehr
von der korona kette lassen und die
zukunft schaut ja durchaus positiv
es zeichnet sich wohl ab dass ähnlich
wie in der finanzkrise 2008 2009 die
kleinteiligkeit unserer wirtschaft um
die doch in sehr viel geringerem maße
fehlende oder ausrichtung auf den export
möglicherweise von vorteil ist in der
krise können solche kleinen unternehmen
sehr viel flexibler reagieren
wir müssen sie nur jetzt in der krise
auch ein stück wird unterstützen die
zeit drängt möglichst schnell sondern
neues rettungskonzept von bund und
ländern stehen die sprung schwestern
hoffen sehr darauf nachrichten nun von
gundula gause mit konkreten forderungen
nach milliardenausgaben für forschung
innovation und bildung geht die
zuständige bundesministerin carlitscheck
in die beratungen über das geplante
konjunkturprogramm als lehre aus der
korona krise müsse mehr in schulen und
universitäten investiert werden aber
auch in zukunftsfelder wie künstliche
intelligenz und technologie forschung
einen schwerpunkt will italien check bei
der erzeugung von grünem wasserstoff
setzen
dabei wird mit hilfe von erneuerbaren
energien wasserstoff aus wasser
abgespalten
die zahl der politisch motivierten
straftaten in deutschland ist im
vergangenen jahr deutlich angestiegen
größte gefahr sei nach wie vor der
rechtsextremismus betonte innenminister
seehofer bei der vorstellung der
polizeistatistik darin werden rund
41.000 politisch motivierte straftaten
aufgeführt bei über der hälfte stammen
die tatverdächtigen aus dem rechten
spektrum
auf ihr konto gehen auch fast alle
antisemitischen straftaten hier gab es
einen anstieg um 13 prozent
zugleich wird bei gewaltdelikten etwa
körperverletzung einen rückgang um knapp
16 prozent verzeichnet
der aus der afc ausgeschlossene
bisherige landesparteichef brandenburgs
kalbitz wehrt sich juristisch gegen den
rauswurf aus seiner partei beim
bundesschiedsgericht habe er beantragt
die annulierung seiner mitgliedschaft
aufzuheben erklärte kalbitz und kündigte
auch zivilrechtliche schritte an
der bundesvorstand hatte sich für den
parteiausschluss entschieden weil
kalbitz beim eintritt in die a f
die frühere mitgliedschaften bei einer
rechtsextremen vereinigung und bei den
republikanern nicht angegeben hatte
in den usa hat der tod eines
afroamerikaners empörung und neue
proteste gegen rassistische
polizeigewalt ausgelöst auf einem handy
video ist zu sehen wie weiße polizisten
in minneapolis minuten lang einen
schwarzen verdächtigen zu boden drücken
der mann ringt nach luft und stirbt
wenig später im krankenhaus
die beteiligten polizisten würden
entlassen das fbi ermittelt in der stadt
demonstrierten hunderte menschen gegen
polizeigewalt dabei kam es zu
zusammenstößen mit den einsatzkräften in
hongkong spitzt sich die
auseinandersetzung zwischen
demonstranten und der regierung weiter
zu massiv ist dort die polizei gegen
aktivisten vorgegangen die gegen das von
china geplante sogenannte
sicherheitsgesetz protestierten etwa 300
menschen wurden festgenommen
die kürzlich vorgelegten pläne der
regierung in peking haben die
massenproteste in der
sonderverwaltungszone hongkong wieder
beliebt die demonstranten fürchten den
verlust von freiheiten und einen zu
starken einfluss chinas eine nachricht
aus den usa heute könnte auftakt werden
zur folgenreichsten und
unwahrscheinlichsten scheidung des
jahres
das verhältnis zwischen präsident trump
und twitter zeigt plötzlich und sehr
öffentlich einen klaffenden riss quer
durch das fundament ihrer beziehung die
route ja darauf dass trump twitter jeden
tag hunderte millionen klicks verschafft
und twitter dafür alles verbreitet was
der kunde trump so zusammen schreibt
ungeachtet lästiger faktoren wie zb
fakten bis heute gegners und plötzlich
hat twitter einem tweet von real donald
trump ein hinweis auf fakten gestützte
artikel wie einen warnhinweis
hinzugefügt es geht auch nicht um
irgendeinen tweet es geht um das thema
briefwahl und darum den verdacht dass
trump versucht vorsorglich zweifel gegen
briefwahlen zu sehen
falls er die wahl im november nicht
gewinnt
also geht es um viel mehr als um eine
weitere absurde trump twitter geschichte
des trams berichtet präsident trump und
twitter eine symbiose nun droht sie zu
zerbrechen wegen eines tweets von trump
indem er briefwahl als substanziell
betrügerisch beschreibt twitter lässt
das nicht stehen fügt dem tweet einen
hinweis an
dieser vorwurf sei unbegründet und
verlinkt ihn mit informationen zum thema
briefwahl daraufhin droht trump die
republikaner haben den eindruck dass
plattformen der sozialen medien
konservative stimmen total zum schweigen
bringen wollen
wir werden sie streng regulieren oder
schließen bevor wir zulassen dass das
noch einmal passiert
man kann nicht twitter einfach
abschalten vor allem nicht aus
politischen gründen
es gilt redefreiheit aber es gibt andere
mögliche regulatorische maßnahmen die er
oder seine regierung ergreifen könnten
nun tram heute auf dem weg nach florida
er ist unter druck in umfragen liegt er
hinter dem kandidat der demokraten er
kämpft gegen twitter und gegen briefwahl
je mehr menschen an der
präsidentschaftswahl teilnehmen fürchtet
er um so schlechter könnte das für ihn
ausgehen belegt ist das nicht krank aber
zeichnet ein schreckensbild die leute
stehlen die anträge leute drucken und
unterschreiben sie auch niemand
realisiert dass da doppelt gezählt wurde
leute zwingen andere mit den bögen für
jemand zustimmen
wir wollen nicht dass die staaten
briefwahl machen es führt zu komplettem
wahlbetrug briefwahl in den usa ein eher
ungewohntes verfahren doch in corona
zeiten wollen einige bundesstaaten es
verstärkt anwenden
trump drohte michigan bereits mit dem
entzug von geldern und die
republikanische partei verklagt
kalifornien weil sie briefwahlanträge
versenden
wir wollen den menschen die möglichkeit
geben und die wahl wie sie wählen wollen
sie sollen ihre gesundheit nicht in
einem beengten raum aufs spiel setzen
müssen da wollen wir ihnen mich rief war
eine weitere option geben
der kandidat der demokraten hält dagegen
wege für mehr wahlbetrug bei briefwahl
gebe es nicht
es gibt überhaupt keinen beleg dafür
dass briefwahl wahlbetrug bedeutet der
präsident legt einfach immer beim thema
wählen kämpft eine einfache briefwahl
für alle will er nicht er selber hat
übrigens das letzte mal seine stimme per
briefwahl abgegeben
unser laufendes jahrhundert ist zu einem
fünftel schon vorbei und alles deutet
darauf hin es wird ein chinesisches
jahrhundert das reich der mitte spielt
seine grösse aus auf jahrtausenden
geschichte ruhen tief verwurzelt
dynamisch furchteinflößend überwältigend
einschüchternd und raumgreifend die
pandemie aus dem industriellen herz von
china stürzt die globale wirtschaft in
eine krise wie es sonst nur große kriege
vermochten aber natürlich wirkt ihre
kraft auch schädlich nach china nach
innen macht dort bruchlinien sichtbar
unsere korrespondenten in peking
stefanie schöneborn und ulf röller sind
in den letzten wochen durch china
gereist um das alles aus der nähe zu
erleben
das war eine einmalige chance für
reporter hier ihr bericht ein vor blick
auf ihre große doku gleich nach dem
heute journal
als kind kletterte songgenie nach pilzen
die in den felsspalten wuchsen
jetzt sucht er nach handys und ruhen
es ist ein waghalsiges geschäftsmodell
inmitten des nationalparks in südchina
denn derzeit kommen kaum noch touristen
und reisegruppen gar nicht der song hat
eigentlich keine angst abzustürzen
aber das corona virus macht ihm sorgen
während der hochsaison kommen hier
zehntausende von touristen jetzt sind es
gerade mal ein paar tausend in ningbo
einer der größten harten städte chinas
türmen sich die container
wochenlang stand hier alles still die
container werden noch immer nicht
befüllt häfen weltweit laufen nicht auf
hochtouren
wir treffen einen wanderarbeiter aus der
inneren mongolei
die angst vor dem wirtschaftlichen
bankrott und vor dem virus begegnet uns
überall
also wenn ich sage dass ich keine angst
vor euch ausländern habe dann würde ich
angeben
im hohen norden der inneren mongolei hat
das virus die grenzen dicht gemacht nur
noch züge fahren sonst schieben sich
hier güter im milliardenwert über die
grenze es wirkt wie die kulisse eines
endzeitfilm weit außerhalb der stadt in
den weiten des graslandes begegnen wir
dem pferdehalterin er stellt uns seine
sehr geselligen freunde vor
sie streiten sich über die herkunft des
führers china oder usa die von
propaganda und bier getrennte antwort
die epidemie ist gekommen das ist
schlecht für alle das ursprungsland ist
nicht schlimm aber amerika auch nicht
kein mensch und keine organisation kann
sagen woher das los kommt und china wird
niemals zugeben woher aber so zu geben
dass es eine epidemie in china unsere
reise vom norden bis in den süden des
landes hat uns ein verändertes china
gezeigt es ist nicht dass china der
chinesischen propaganda
das land ist ärmer repressiver brutaler
als wir es vorher kannten corona hat die
widersprüche des landes sichtbarer
gemacht die aufstrebende weltmacht
erlebt ihre schwerste krise
an der börse war die lufthansa heute
thema deren aufsichtsrat hat wegen
möglicher auflagen der eu-kommission
überraschend die annahme des milliarden
schweren rettungspaketes vertagt die
lufthansa braucht aber die staatlichen
hilfen frank bethmann
wo liegen die probleme in den
verhandlungen mit den eu
wettbewerbshütern
die wettbewerbshüter in brüssel fordern
dass die lufthansa mehr start und
landerechte abgeben soll als diese das
will
dazu muss man wissen diese sogenannten
slots vor allem die die lufthansa an
ihren wichtigen drehkreuzen frankfurt
und münchen hat sind gold wert dort wird
das große geld verdient und zwei drittel
aller dieser slots hält die lufthansa
sowohl in frankfurt als auch in münchen
und genau das ist brüssel ein dorn im
auge dort will man mehr wettbewerb es
soll um 20 slots gehen die die lufthansa
an die konkurrenz abgeben soll
die lufthansa wehrt sich sie würde
wichtige zubringerflüge verlieren in
münchen und frankfurt sammelt sie aus
ganz europa fluggäste für ihre
gewinnbringenden transatlantikflüge die
würden verloren gehen und damit wohl
auch jährlich gewinne im dreistelligen
millionenbereich
und überhaupt schimpft die lufthansa die
auf neun milliarden euro wartet über
ungleichbehandlung auch andere
europäische airlines erhalten milliarden
an staatlichen rettungsgeldern oder
haben sie in den letzten jahren bekommen
die lufthansa ist zwischen die
politischen fronten geraten dort die
wettbewerbshüter die der airline
wichtiges geschäft wegnehmen wollen hier
die bundesregierung die auch nach corona
eine starke lufthansa haben will
denn nur die kann künftig zinsen in
millionenhöhe an den staat zurückzahlen
der poker um die lufthansa geht jetzt
also in die nächste runde
vielen dank und auch heute rollt der
ball wieder in der fußball-bundesliga am
frühen abend spielten rb leipzig und
hertha bsc unentschieden 2 2
die gewinnzahlen vom lotto am mittwoch
lauten wie immer ohne gewähr
425 36 39 43 47 superzahl 3 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7
die allerletzten vorbereitungen in cape
canaveral in florida laufen
hier live zu sehen und in 20 minuten
soll es soweit sein die erste bemannte
us rakete seit 2011 startet richtung iss
die rakete vom typ falcon 9 wird nicht
von der nasa sondern von spacex ins all
befördert das raumfahrtunternehmen des
milliardärs elon musk transportiert seit
acht jahren material zur internationalen
raumstation
und jetzt also auch die erfahrenen us
astronauten robert behnken und douglas
hurley das us raumfahrer in russischen
raketen mit fliegen müssen sollen nun
gleich ein ende haben das ist nun wieder
das livebild aus florida um genau 22 uhr
32 unserer zeit soll die rakete starken
live auf zdf heute mit zu verfolgen
lady gaga wäre selbst dann ein superstar
wenn sie allein auf ihre
darstellungskunst angewiesen wäre und
nicht auch noch eine großartige
musikerin
sie trotzt der pandemie und bietet jetzt
ihr sechstes studioalbum an plus eine
ganze neue koma gesättigte welt als
optisches bonus pack claudio armbruster
hat dazu ihr einziges tv interview für
deutschland wenn ein mensch so
außergewöhnlich ist so kompromisslos
kreativ dann fragt man sich doch was ist
da eigentlich los in diesem interview
wollen wir wissen was treibt sie an lady
gaga als ich sehr jung war habe ich
rainer maria rilke gelesen
seine briefe an einen jungen dichter
darin heißt es gestehen sie sich ein ob
sie sterben müssten wenn es ihnen
versagt würde zu schreiben
fragen sie sich in der stillsten stunde
ihrer nacht musste ich schreiben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie muss schreiben und wie bei so vielen
künstlern entsteht ihre kunst aus einer
traurigkeit und unsicherheit mit der
welt ich habe depressionen und ich muss
medikamente dagegen ein
stellen sie sich vor sie wären niemals
wirklich glück egal wie gut sie leben
oder was die anderen sagen
stellen sie sich vor sie haben einen
können ein talent und sind sich aber
nicht sicher ob sie gut sind aber ich
versuche es für ihr neues album hat sich
eine neue welt erschaffen bunt schrill
fröhlich
sie nennen sie chromatik romantiker ist
die welt in meinem kopf meine art zu
liegen meine art freundlich zu sein
dieses album heilt mich es ist der tanz
durch meinen schmerz noch ein neues
video rain on me zusammen mit jana
grandi mainstream-pop für millionen auf
der einen seite auf der anderen seite
skurrile performance kunst mit der
künstlerin marina abramovic 2013 haut
auf eis schmerz und schonungslose
nacktheit auch das ist lady gaga ich bin
nicht perfekt aber ich feiere mich
selbst als frau meine karriere war in
vielerlei hinsicht ein aufbegehren gegen
die dinge die männer von mir verlangten
die männer wollten meine lieder anderen
frauen geben frauen die gar nicht singen
konnten und die diese lieder gar nicht
komponiert hatten
der grund war ich sage nicht so gut aus
ich musste hart kämpfen um das zu
behalten was erschaffen habe es geht
nicht ums aussehen es geht um herz und
verstand und darum was man kann
[Musik]
so hat sie es einst gesungen
das neue album chromatischer ihr
sechstes soll gute laune machen sagt sie
um die schmerzen weg zu tanzen
das nennt man wohl starken abgang der
weitere verlauf des abends sieht
idealerweise so aus jetzt die reportage
die dokumentation aus china von ulf
röller und stefanie schöne baum dann
pausetaste 23 minuten start in cape
canaveral zurückkehren kann nicht alles
haben manchmal schon aber seit heute
immer
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
ist in bosnien und herzegowina in
serbien und auch hier in montenegro mit
20 grad mal kühler ist als gleichzeitig
in großbritannien hier in london mit 25
grad ist selten aber morgen ist es
soweit und das bleibt auch in den
nächsten tagen so denn die temperaturen
hier im westen und südwesten europas wie
sind eher hoch während sich hier über
südosteuropa doch eher die kältere luft
hat jetzt eine nacht ist es bei uns
besonders kalt am alpenrand aber auch in
der lüneburger heide dort sinken die
temperaturen auf 6 bis 4 grad deutlich
milder bleibt es zwischen der neiße und
der saane 12 bis 8 grad und das liegt
daran dass dort eine kleine kaltfront
liegt die bringt regen mit und hier in
sachsen da kann es besonders viel regnen
da sind das so fünf bis 20 liter regen
pro quadratmeter in dieser nacht klar
ist der himmel dagegen ganz im norden
und auch ganz im süden morgen über tag
kommt die kaltfront dann am alpenrand an
da sind auch einzelne gewitter durchaus
möglich und hiervon polen ziehen auch
einige regenschauer zu uns rein sonst
wechseln sonne und wolken miteinander ab
und zwischen nordfriesland und der mosel
scheint die sonne strahlt in der nähe
der küste und in der luft und bei regen
wolken bleibt es morgen bei 15 bis 18
grad kühl
sonst steigen die temperaturen im
binnenland auf 19 bis 24 grad
in den nächsten tagen ändert sich beim
wetter wenig im südosten gibt es
häufiger dichtere wolken das gilt dann
auch noch für das pfingstwochenende der
pfingstmontag bringt uns von allen viel
sonnenschein und wärme schönen abend
noch